Сучасна фотографія —
це картинка плюс висловлювання ваше.
Дуже важливо, що ти хочеш сказати.
Якщо цього нема — жодних шансів у тебе нема.
Це персональне питання:
«Чому це сталося? Як насправді щось відбувається?»
І я починаю працювати з цим.
Це, переважно, стосується якихось бід, проблем, буття.
Хто немає голосу сказати, щоб він був почутий.
Я їхній голос, наприклад.
Творчість — це єдина річ,
у якій людина може  почувати себе вільною.
Там ти — творець вже.
Ти — творець, і ти встановлюєш свої правила,
і за ними граєш, за цими правилами.
А так ти граєш за чужими.
Фотографія — демократичний вид мистецтва,
тому що ми можемо взяти телефон і фотографувати,
а телефон є у кожного.
Він дозволяє людині бути вільною.
Робота, яка пов'язана із задоволенням.
Якщо там немає задоволення — я звідти йду.
Зараз я займаюся, наприклад, архівами,
архівною роботою з фотографією,
шукаю фотографію — і для мене це дуже цікаво.
З різного боку: я люблю фотографувати,
люблю проявляти плівку, друкувати,
робити рамки для фотографій, розвішувати ці фотографії,
дивитися на зльотах колекціонерів,
які відбуваються в Києві, старі фотографії.
Я передивився кілька тисяч фотографій, просто собі.
І мені це ну, знаєте, мені це дуже було цікаво,
тому що це — занурення в якісь життя такі,
і ти там знаходиш такі цікаві розповіді, ходи якісь.
З цих домашніх архівів. Розумієте?
Весь комплекс, пов'язаний із фотографією
і з фотографічним зображенням, мені цікавий.
Ну фотографій є три.
Це є медійна: журналістика або документальна.
Ну все!
Це чиста фотографія, яка відображає життя.
Ну, для медіа.
Далі йде комерційна фотографія.
Це, яка робиться на замовлення.
Ну, як вона працює, як і в усьому світі вона працює.
Є рекламна агенція, вона приймає
замовлення, розробляє бріф,
і замовляє це продакшн-студії.
У продакшн-студії є фотограф,
який вже виконує накази,
тому що це все вже розписано.
Тобто в продакшн-студії
фотограф немає такої свободи творчої.
Він виконує завдання.
Ну і останнє — це арт.
Ну, я, як фотограф,
доволі багато знаю про фотографію,
яка стосується війни. І вона — різна.
Є новинна, журналістська фотографія,
є фотографія документальна,
котра робиться трошки по часу по-іншому,
ніж така, яку треба зробити новинному фотографу,
і в цей же день передати фотографії,
і вони мають у цей же день бути опублікованими, і таке інше.
Зараз для мене найважливіше —
це бути на фронті й фотографувати там.
І якщо я тут, а не там, я на це так думаю,
що це просто витрачений час.
А тем тут [багато].
Сюди приїжджають фотографувати
багато фотографів з усього світу.
На початку 2000-х я потрапив на бієнале у Венецію,
потім була бієнале в Сан-Пауло.
І все.
І коли я повернувся з Сан-Пауло,
я вирішив, що закінчувати треба з фотографією,
тому що фотографія — як спорт:
якщо в тебе вже вік або погана форма — важко знімати.
Тому що серйозна фотографія потребує тем,
треба якусь тему розкривати.
Треба відкривати якусь тему із зануренням якимось туди.
Це забирає дуже багато сил,
тому що в мене дві основні теми, які я продав,
продав я у широкому сенсі цього слова:
не продав за гроші, а зробив популярним.
Це Чорнобиль, на який у мене пішло, ну, я не знаю, 25 років.
З перших днів, з восьмого травня,
і останній раз я був, ну я думаю, в якому році?
Я уже не пам'ятаю, в 2011 [році], може, десь.
Багато років пішло на це все.
І потім були шахти-копанки —
це була робота з швейцарською кіногрупою.
Вони знімали фільм,
вони мене запросили, найняли на роботу.
Вони паралельно випустили книгу,
і я працював для книги.
Абсолютно вільний я був,
тобто, жодних завдань, нічого,
вони мене не тиснули.
Абсолютно я — вільний, що хотів — те й знімав.
І потім вони випустили книгу,
і всі авторські права перейшли повністю мені.
Вони, навіть, зняли свою студію [назву],
«Lotus Films» зняли з підписів.
От, що потрібно було для того,
щоб стати фотографом?
Перше — це слухати якісну музику, класичну музику.
Друге — це дивитися гарне зображення.
Ну гарне яке?
Потрібне зображення, якісне зображення.
І живопис. Ти ходиш у галереї, в музеї, і дивишся.
А третє — це ти фотографувати багато маєш.
Але це третє вже.
Спочатку я вчився сам.
Ну, були люди, котрим я задавав різні питання,
якщо мені було щось не, чогось я не розумів.
Такого, як наставника, чи мій вчитель,
такого не було нікого.
Але був ряд людей до котрих я звертався.
Я досі навчаюсь.
У 2004 році я повернувся, і вирішив,
що я не буду, ну я не кажу, що я не буду  знімати,
але я не буду просувати,
я не буду серйозно знімати.
І німецька дружина,
німкеня в мене була на той час,
ну вона є зараз, але ми не живемо разом.
От, і вона мені сказала: «Що ти, як старий дурень,
будеш бігати з камерою? Роби школу».
І ми в 2004 році зробили школу.
Ми хочемо просто, щоб наші люди,
які хочуть серйозно займатися фотографією,
були підключені, хоч мінімально,
до тих міжнародних освітніх програм,
які існують сьогодні на заході.
Тому що сьогодні вивчати фотографію,
припустимо, в Америці — це треба шість років.
Мене інколи питають:
«А коли ти розумієш, що потрібно закінчити тему?
Коли вона закінчується?»
Ну, коли ти висловився.
Коли тобі вже немає що говорити,
у тебе були якісь думки,
і ти висловився, ти сказав все, що думаєш,
все, що у тебе на душі, і все цим закінчується.
У 1999 році [була] остання зйомка —
це похорони шахтарів.
Було 63 шахтаря, і на шахті ім. О.Ф. Засядька загинули.
І я вже, ну, все.
У кінці 1994 року Віктор Марущенко
повернувся із Швейцарії,
і ми з ним сиділи, розмовляли,
і мова зайшла про те, що шахтарі —
дуже цікава така спільнота у світі.
Там, де є шахтарські міста,
там, де ці селища є гірняцькі —
там зовсім інша атмосфера,
і вони дуже сильно впливають на політику країни.
Візьмемо, наприклад, ситуацію Маргарет Тетчер з шахтарями,
коли вона закрила, свого часу, шахти,
і це дуже така велика, сильна була подія,
яка до цих пір відлуння є її, наприклад, в Англії.
І Віктор каже, що цікаво було б поїхати на Донечинну,
подивитись що там відбувається,
тому що за радянських часів Донецьк,
донецький регіон —
це був такий привілейований робітничий клас.
І ми поїхали туди, подивилися, було дуже цікаво,
ми потрапили в зовсім інше середовище:
там були свої князі, свої володарі —
все зовсім своє,
і йшов дуже великий розпад економіки,
тому що закривались шахти.
Шахти — важкі, важке добування вугілля,
воно — дуже дороге і немає сенсу його добувати.
Краще в Польщі, наприклад, або в Туреччині купити.
Але справа в тому, що будь-яка шахта —
це не тільки промисловість, це й інфраструктура.
Селище, шахтарське селище —
закривається шахта, і життя там немає.
За день до штурму Іловайська.
Це — Грабське.
Попасна.
Саме момент, коли батальйон «Донбас»
переїжджав із Попасної до Курахове,
звідки він почав штурмувати Іловайськ.
Це коли для мене закінчився Іловайськ:
це моя нога, а це поранений Ізя,
позовний — Ізя в нього.
Він був, він працював на коксохімії там.
Насправді, він — місцевий хлопець.
Оце — іграшки хлопчика з Дебальцево.
Це — у Запоріжжі.
Вони з мамою втекли з Дебальцево.
Ось цей хлопчик — Богданчик його звати.
Він дуже хотів, щоб я його з цим сфотографував.
А це трофей у Лисичанську,
там багато такого було.
Це про те з ким ми воюємо, насправді.
Вони переховувалися в підвалі
під дитячим садочком два тижні.
Військові принесли їжу, ліки і воду,
вони дуже боялися відчиняти,
думали, що їх будуть вбивати,
ґвалтувати, відрізати голови.
Так і сказали.
Коли зрозуміли, що нічого цього не буде —
почали плакати всі, практично.
Ось цей хлопець.
Це мій друг.
Він сам походженням із Донецька.
Я познайомився, це, мабуть, був 2008 рік.
Я фотографував його з родиною,
з дітьми, а потім зустрів у батальйоні «Донбас».
Це він вийшов із полону,
якщо пам'ятаєте, наприкінці 2014 року,
і зустрічається з дружиною тут в Києві.
Тут краще цей відбиток.
І, як заведено, жінки в нас більш сміливі,
саме ця жінка запитувала чи будуть вбивати.
Тобто, вона так дивилася
на цього військового, і він каже:
«Ви, мабуть, хочете мене щось запитати?»
Вона: «Так, так».
Чи будемо ми вас тут зараз
ґвалтувати, відрізати вам голови? Так?
І всі кажуть: «Так, так, так».
Він: «Навіщо? У мене така сама
жінка вдома чекає, як ви».
І все.
Це Курахово.
Сфотографувати і висловитись — це різні речі.
Все ж таки сьогодні, якщо подивитись
зірок американських або європейських,
ну, більше це стосується
американських зірок фотографій,
я вам скажу, якщо ви подивитесь CV [резюме] їхні,
то ви побачите, що вони мають дві освіти.
Перша освіта — це психологія,
антропологія, соціологія —
обов'язково вони мають
таку освіту, ну, якусь гуманітарну.
І друга освіта — фотографічна.
І вони дуже складно, дуже складною мовою,
зашифрованою мовою
розповідають про дуже складні речі.
Ці речі можуть бути суспільні, громадянські,
а можуть бути особисті.
І вони про це розповідають.
Оце і є мистецтвом фотографії.
Сучасна мова — це мова інстаграму, мова мобілографії,
тобто селфі.
Селфі, я вважаю, що селфі — це дуже цікава річ.
Це людина, знову ж, повертається до себе,
і дивиться на себе, і хоче себе зрозуміти.
І ступінь розуміння — ну, це така річ,
знаєте, залежить вже від особистості.
Але це повернення до себе,
і те, що я хочу зрозуміти хто я, де я,
який я в якихось ситуаціях.
Я думаю, що це для людини, для того,
щоб розуміти себе — це дуже важливо.
Тому, от, наприклад, ваше покоління — це покоління селфі.
Ви хочете себе зрозуміти.
Це дуже добре.
Це рівень свободи знов, новий рівень свободи.
Від того, що сьогодні всі мають смартфон із камерою —
середній рівень фотографії не піднявся.
Розумієте?
Тому що вона стала більш складною.
І я весь час кажу всім нашим учням:
«Для того, щоб просуватися — треба навчатися».
І не обов'язково фотографії.
Треба знати про що ви хочете сказати.
Ось тут.
Просто я ще досі промивки всі роблю у ванні.
Отут має бути така велика ванна,
вода вже є, немає зворотного руху ще, не зробили.
Коли зроблять — це буде один із осередків раю для мене.
А це плівка на наступну подорож до фронту.
Пів сотні штук.